coach fois par terre ouais continues tu
partageras une cellule avec ton père
aurait un temps je sais plus quoi faire
on en revient toujours à cette
conversation encore et encore personne
n'a demandé d'être mal ça va être guy
alors il y à moi et toi tu te souviens
ou est ce que tu vas ans fauchée pas
est ce que ben laden est là
koné le père de son fils on l'a retrouvé
ce matin il est mort
alors tu es sûr que tu sais pas où il
est je suis sûr ne ment pas tu pense
qu'il aurait pu faire ça la police va y
trouver ensuite on essaiera de
comprendre que tu dois te ressaisir tu
dois faire quelque chose c'est ton frère
parce que s'ils le trouvent ils vont
l'arrêter il note que toi est-ce que tu
travailles à hier soir j'ai juste besoin
d'une information
comment oses-tu montrer ta face à
presque ton frère à frère disparu n'est
pas coupable
n'essaie pas de nous cacher quelque
chose emilie la vérité je te crois
faut juste que je trouve qu est ce que
tu fais tes pas la police y avait
quelqu'un d'autre la bannière soir
comment vous avez su que j'étais là bas
je veux pas de voir appliquer dans une
affaire dont tu ne pourras pas de sortir
ne bouge pas
trouve la mirabelle la merde mais qu'est
ce que tu fais c'est mon frère où il est
personne est essentiel mourir ok tu
penses que brenda meurtri mais je sais
pas
je sais comment il